okay girl
i'm not gonna get mad at her no no no no
you ready yeah yeah he said no they set
that up yeah they set that up they set
that up
they said that up but she died
which will i ain't mad at you live your
life there's just certain phrases let's
go leighton just know
wow nice feet
10 out of 10.
wow okay contestant one let's see you
have some marks on your toenails what's
that from uh
from me dropping like tools and other
random crap okay i like the woodwork and
stuff so so you like hit your feet a
couple times that's awesome uh more than
a couple that sounds painful solid solid
feet okay love that thank you okay
contestant two um hello
feet as well looking
great not a lot this episode feels
really gay
i don't think i've ever stared at men's
feet this long what
i feel gay
because the other episode we're staring
at women's feet no i'm staring at just a
bunch of dude's feet it feels
uncomfortable i don't think i've ever
stared at a man's feet my whole life and
that's gay looking at feet man's feet
yeah
yeah everything is okay to you no
no no everything's just gay in the world
that's facts that's why we have the word
pause listen go up to any [ __ ] in the
hood and say yo you're trying to look at
some men's feet that's not what no no no
no i'm asking i'll be asking you no no
no no your
because i'm asking you to look at
something look look you know how the
thing is looking at man feeds is not gay
asking a [ __ ] if you want to
look at me that's gay
no
go to the beach and start staring at
dude's feet i promise you somebody will
have a problem with you eventually
yay
yeah you have to think about it because
you're like actually you don't mind i'll
rely tell the truth i just don't know
i'm telling the truth i don't know
but have you ever thought of doing it
no because i'm not attracted to feet
like that i'm not i'm not going to be
like and i'm wearing me attracting his
feet i'm just like oh [ __ ] no that's not
a thing no bro this is the same like
it's not i'm not i'm like i'm not gonna
look at motherfucker's knees i'm not
gonna [ __ ] look look at me and i
don't think i've ever had [ __ ] look at
my feet
not a single time my whole life ever
it's like i could understand hands
right
what are you staring at feet it just
feels weird but but the hands is not
good i think i feel like hands is
scarier than feet how i don't know this
is what guys do we just spend
look at that really look at that man's
hands man
okay she's like yo but you got you got
really close friends i was like yeah
i've got some really close friends like
why do they like you though
i was like what you mean so you never
think about why your male friends like
you i was like that's gay
no it's not that's gay no it's not
why why would i think about why my
homies like me it's like you can't even
say the word like
yo you like abba
but do you like him yo stop with that
[ __ ] yeah
i already answered that question so you
think about why your homies like you
i don't
no it's like if you like a [ __ ]
you could say you i like a [ __ ]
you could i agree okay it's like feet i
could look at feet
but i can't ask a [ __ ] let's go
look at feet that's right so i'm not
going to ask a [ __ ] let's go
look her feet or yo why you like like do
do you think about think about why you
like your friends and why their friends
like you but i always think about my
homies feet that's weird too
that's weird
i'm not even talking about thinking
about your hobie's feet but that's my
thing because now you having
recollections and [ __ ] that's what oh
yeah i remember his feet that's cause
you got a fetish nah bro listen let me
tell you one time i stared at bradley's
feet real quick i was like [ __ ]
but now we're staring all this to say
all this is the same all this decision
all this i am not on all this to say i'm
so straight like it's crazy
you're not straight
you're scared of being gay that's what
you that's you
that's you scared of being gay no you at
this point at this point bro it's
honestly just funny
you scared of being gay
why would i be scared you're not scared
of being gay
that's gay
i am what i am it's like if you straight
you don't have to worry about being
there oh you know you know but it is
funny to be like posh
you're oh yeah you you you're the pause
dude by excellence
it's necessary no it's not it's
absolutely necessary no it's not yeah
yeah people will be saying something
like pods bro that's small
you're moving well you got to say it
if you know that you're not gay you know
that you don't get you don't have to
pause it okay okay bro
there's there's a joke there's a
difference between being serious and
being joking i enjoy saying it because i
think it's funny
right because there's a moment where you
say something that can be taken a
certain way and it's just funny to be
like plus listen it's not that deep yeah
but that's you there yes that's me but
you should know that no i don't yeah you
do how should i know that
you do how should i know that because
you've been around me for years i don't
know you like that [ __ ] that's kept
that's not that's kept how's it going
because because you will say that's you
[ __ ] is that your life that's the but
yeah when i recognize it i recognize
some [ __ ] yes yes some [ __ ] but not
everything but not everything i'm gonna
be like oh yeah that's definitely i know
exactly this about no there's a bunch of
[ __ ] i don't know about you that's facts
[ __ ] i don't know you would think about
a month ago you didn't tell me that's
facts but there's a difference between
things you wouldn't be able to observe
and things you observe all the time
that's a difference yeah but i pay
attention to you like that's cap no
because you're not wow [ __ ] cause you
know what i'm saying that cause you know
you cuz you know why
he does his face or his face like crinks
just a second when he's about to see
some [ __ ]
because you know why yeah yeah look at
you guys
but that's no but i don't know
everything about you i don't i didn't
say you know everything about me that's
gay
calm down that's okay
now that is
oh man you stupid with this one no no no
here's the thing it's like there's
certain things i don't think about i got
my homies we appreciate each other we
were able to compliment each other show
each other love that's never been an
issue right yeah i don't be like but why
do y'all like me
i just couldn't imagine asking that
question or even really think about
deeply but why is it important that's
that's girl [ __ ] that's
that's what i said to her
that's something a girl would say to me
on a date why do you like me
yeah you gave me like here's the thing
i've thought about why i'm likable to
win
i thought about that why because i've
it's almost like applying for a job you
have to put in an effort to make sure
you present yourself a certain way
it's really funny because i really think
about how you're dislikable to women
oh i think about that too yeah yeah i
mean i've told you i'm very dislikeable
in some ways people definitely yeah
but i think about that consciously
because it's necessary for me to get
where i want to get right if i want
women to like me i have to understand
what it is about me that they like so i
can amplify it yeah being self-conscious
with guys i've never had to think about
that because friendships with dudes have
never been a convoluted process they're
not like chase me they're not like oh
show me you care right [ __ ] just like
that the the rock which or they don't
that's that's it right i've never had to
think about that process okay so okay
see the way when you say is gay
when you say it's gay i
my translation of that is
you complicated
yeah there's some complicated
[ __ ] and there's some
uncomplicated [ __ ] and the
relationship that let's say
the the relation that dudes typical
dudes are going to have is not
complicated like that i agree it's it's
not i got that i got i gotta agree all
right so
i don't even think it's just it's
complicated it's also got like a bit of
a feminine twist to it
i feel like it's much more likely for
women to pay attention than other
women's feet you get what i'm saying
sure because they'd be paying attention
to pedicures and manicures and all that
kind of stuff you get what i'm saying
it's much more their likelihood to pay
attention to the finer details of
somebody's look in that regards than it
would be for a man you know what i'm
saying right so if a woman told me she
was staring at a
another woman's feet you wouldn't even
think about it no you wouldn't no
you hear yo hey [ __ ] i'm out here
[Applause]
you i know you can't say that [ __ ] you
said that too i'd be like pause it which
is fine but i don't know you you can't
even finish that thing because it's a
weird okay i know but i could finish
just let it be like
paws but you can't even fan of design
that's weird right i'm not crazy bro
that was weird
that's weird just you saying it right
now you're like
that's weird there's just certain things
just like bruh
the only way to undo that [ __ ] is if you
did
yo
your feet look busted my g yeah
you think you undid that cause your [ __ ]
was so [ __ ] up that you have to say it
but you can't be like
your feet kinda cute you
on the whole past thing you know what's
funny to me is if someone said you'll
have a deconstruct that do you think
it's a good thing they're saying that
objectively probably not no it's not
probably not but
i like what i like you know that's just
so much fun to do i don't know i just
get a kick out of it because sometimes
you'll be saying stuff
such stuff and then you call them on it
and then they just like yeah okay that
was us and you just keep pushing ao is
the new pause shout out to my [ __ ]
names
hey yo no calm down like you know what i
mean talk about feet and so i remember
what she when i told you she asked me
that question she's like okay well think
about it i'm like no i'm not gonna think
about it because i don't care
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
not an issue if my homie came to me was
like yo bro i think you're a stand-up
dude or i think you know what the way
that you handle your business or the way
that you take care of your family or the
way the way that you know you achieve
your girl whatever it might be okay
i think there's much more liberty and
the people well abba you're imposing
that on yourself i'm not complaining you
get what i'm saying like i'm not trying
to be out here getting manicures and
pedicures i have zero curiosity
right the same way when she asked me
that question she's like you don't think
about why i've never in my entire life
ever thought about why am i homeless no
it's like it's not like that and i don't
i
i don't ask that question about my
girlfriends
like
you either is or isn't
i'm not gonna ask that
from like it's not me that's not what i
do that's not my thing
that's not my that's not my thing i get
you
my suspicion of why you don't think
about it is because you just present
yourself as yourself yeah you're not
trying to put on specific clothes for
them i'm not
exactly i don't give a [ __ ] right right
but that's what they do yeah
that's you yeah not you but that's them
yeah and i mean so i definitely heard
homegirl say to like about other like i
don't know why that girl even likes
hanging out with me or like being around
me yeah and i'm just like yeah that's it
i've never thought about that with my
own a single time in my entire life so
for me it's not like oh abba you have an
uncomfortableness it's like it's not
about uncomfortable no it doesn't matter
it's just simply because they accept me
for me
we look we look at things differently
right
where other things are going to be more
complicated for a guy and it's going to
be simpler for a girl this [ __ ] this
this is your thing like we don't look at
it like that
and it doesn't matter with my friends of
girl guys if they're uh cis whatever
i don't that's not me that's not what i
do it's really is you here
do you like being here
do i like you being here
if you check the boxes then we cool
if one of the boxes are get you know i
mean if i don't like you here get the
[ __ ] off if you don't like being here
get the [ __ ] off
that's as simple as that i recently got
a pedicure
and i had some color put on
you have to look away
i got you [ __ ]
you have to look away oh that's funny
that's funny
you couldn't just look at it you're like
okay that's too long no i'm staring you
know the minute he said pedicure you
went
that's it
[Music]
the minute he said pedicure you had to
[ __ ] oh okay that's too long i'm
staring now i'm being weird that's what
you
you know what that that is interesting
though what like if you sat a woman here
and she was staring at a bunch of
women's feet she'd be super comfortable
but like you asked most of you to stare
at like men's bodies
all right we're done
listen we i have i have enough
i have enough of old geezers
at the gym yeah the old guys that passed
okay past
55
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you man
at the gym is really like flying hey so
what are you doing johnny it's like
we're not trying to do that i'm trying
to take my shower put my clothes on go
home breath
what are you doing
what is what are you doing my guy
dress up have a talk in the lobby leave
god damn you guys ever wonder why you've
never seen a mop in a male's change
rooms because old [ __ ] balls is just
dragging everywhere everywhere bruh
flopping they're flopping showing to
everybody
look
i think it's interesting jesus and peace
man how the existence i just i've never
been curious about the male anatomy like
that i don't i've never been like i want
to say dude it's never been my thing
every time
okay that's cool that's it
now people like but why though but why
though is there something deeper like
it's not deeper but why what
why are you not trying to stare at dudes
why does it make you uncomfortable it's
like no
i just don't like looking at it okay you
get what i'm saying here's another
example some people have a thing where
like i've heard leagues tell me i don't
like looking at dicks
i'm not mad at you no if you don't like
the way it looks you don't like the way
it looks i know girls are like i don't
like looking that [ __ ] yee whenever i
tell them i receive [ __ ] picks they're
like yeah is that a form of misogyny
or is it a form of like you're actually
in the closet you know what i'm saying
you know what i mean maybe oh okay no
that's just you don't like you don't you
don't like that you don't like that you
don't want to look at it you know it's
not appealing to you it's not appealing
to you that's it i'll make a big thing
out of it like whatever it's like nails
on a chalkboard for me
do you think it's an indication of
something if you're look let's say
you're fine with pda
okay not you but somebody else
but they're uncomfortable when they look
at two dudes kissing they don't manifest
it but they just look away do you think
that's an indication of something yeah
it could it could be right but it's not
necessarily it could be i don't know i
don't know yo the brain is complex
okay you jumping up to confusion say
like it's definitely that
[ __ ] it could be but it could not be as
well it could be something else so i'm
not gonna
the brain is so complex that i'm not
gonna jump and jump the conclusion or
whatever it's maybe just not what you
like it's just maybe not aesthetically
speaking
you don't like that or but maybe you're
not maybe you're
because of the fact that you're not used
to in the society yes
i don't know
i don't know maybe i i do think that
women don't understand that men can be
potentially different in that regards
because they think that because a lot of
them are a little bit bi-curious or they
are attracted to women or they are open
to the idea of kissing women but they
can't understand why a lot of dudes
aren't or they're just like nah we don't
roll like that
she's like maybe we just look different
too i don't know what the answer is i
agree with what you're saying you don't
know
but
i think ladies often times be like well
we can
yes you can but we're not in the same
species the same way
if you have sex you're far more likely
to get attached than a man would right
yeah we built it it's okay to have some
of those differences
and it doesn't mean that men don't get
attached and they get sick that's not
what it means no but i'm just saying
that yeah exactly that's all i'm saying
i'm not saying that [ __ ] is not possible
i'm saying that [ __ ] is yes okay so and
it's like you would like to use the word
spectrum and [ __ ] yeah let's use that as
well for that that's it not likely but
possible how about that i think we
should just make this topic i think um i
know for me from a community standpoint
like
anti-homosexual sentiment was not a
thing that deeply when i was growing up
it really wasn't maybe it was just for
you from a religious standpoint but for
me it wasn't does it mean so i never had
an issue
with the whole lgbtq that i never care
like this one be gay go be gay so i
don't give a [ __ ] what everybody is
doing right but i'm not even gonna fry
one time i was at a club enjoying myself
just dancing with a girl and i looked to
my right and these two dudes were just
making out from me i was like whoop
i'm saying
i just instantly was not like downward
looking and i had to think about it for
some time like is that a bad thing i
don't think it's a bad thing but you
would have the world make you believe it
is yeah but i have a problem boy two
girls like you think two
not because of sexuality thing it's just
because of the pda thing are you being
public in public it's just the pda thing
it depends for me how sexy they are but
i get what you're saying it's just a pda
thing like if i'm dancing and you're on
the dance floor
i'm like [ __ ] we're trying to dance up
in here go do that over there
go do that over there yeah you're like
yeah flashbacks
yeah you know
that's you [ __ ]
it's like this right
i don't give a [ __ ] about cars
if somebody drives a car i'ma look away
because i never want to look at the car
exactly i don't give a [ __ ] about cars
you would might stare at a mclaren or
something about it i don't give a [ __ ]
right yeah i'm all about cars and
machines and stuff like that you know
that right so that's yeah that's my
thing
even when
yeah oh man you try to trigger me when
we drive by saying
stupid [ __ ] like we drive around and he
sees cars oh look at that
hyundai prius and it's a lamborghini
urus and i'm like what the [ __ ] did you
just say oh okay you yo you playing you
playing but
it's not a pinto no stupid it's a prius
same thing right same thing for you man
you don't give a [ __ ] yeah a hyundai
corolla and i'm like what
what the [ __ ] did you oh that mercedes
benz is fired no [ __ ] it's a man on a
bike
but yeah yeah i i just think
i think there's a discussion to be have
because i know for me
there's levels to it right for example
i've heard guys say stuff like
my son is gay sopher but that to me is
weird that that's [ __ ] that's that
that to me is an issue you got issues
you know what i'm saying man it happened
to someone in my church yeah it got
disowned by family and [ __ ] i mean i'm
talking about not yo you're not my son
anymore i'm talking about name in the
newspaper yeah i mean like the thing
while it was legal here like it was i
was like that's [ __ ] yes am i my dad was
livid my dad was pissed the [ __ ] off he
was like yo you can't do that to your
son or whatever but yeah there's some
people like that yeah there's definitely
some people like that yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
well yeah it's a thing
i definitely think it's a it's it's
definitely thing to some degree and i
think probably the genesis a lot of the
pause and all this other stuff bears
from some of that where she's like nah
we're not we're not with them
definitely you know but for me i just
don't even think that deeply like and i
also think if it doesn't manifest in any
outward behavior in terms of like you
don't belong in this space you shouldn't
have access to this you shouldn't have
these rights if you're in my family i'll
treat you if it doesn't manifest now who
cares you know and i think with each
generation folks are getting more
comfortable i don't know if if there's
ever going to be a point where dudes is
like hey man those two kids i could
stare at that i don't know if it's ever
going to get there you know
you know i don't know if it's ever going
to get to a point where like dude's like
yo let me look at your feet i don't know
if it does i don't want to be part of
this planet for sure but otherwise i'm
good the only reason why i'm talking
this much is because i just want to go
back to looking at feet
i hope you realize that
i think uh
i think it's just a topic it's impromptu
so we weren't super researched so don't
be like uh excuse me in 1976 oh look we
listen [ __ ] you know what i don't care
you're so problematic probably all right
we get it no we're having an open
conversation man shut the [ __ ] up such a
horror mouse that's it but just stop
asking dudes why do your friends like
you that's just so gay man
why do your homies like